president Trump agreed to shut down his
personal charity but his fighting
penalties amid allegations he used the
foundation for personal and political
benefit New York's Attorney General is
seeking restitution and penalties for
what she called a shocking pattern of
illegality June mr. Trump promised in a
tweet quote I won't settle this case
major Garrett is at the White House
major good morning good morning
president Trump tried to block this case
and said the New York Attorney General a
Democrat is politically motivated that
Attorney General Barbara Underwood has
asked a judge to bar the president from
serving on the board of any New York
charity for a full decade and wants a
similar prohibition only for one year
though to the president's three eldest
children the Builder president now is
losing his foundation Trump Foundation
small foundation people contribute I
contribute the money goes a hundred
percent 100 percent goes to different
charities but it's been a decade since
the president gave a dime to the charity
according to New York's Attorney General
who said the Trump Foundation function
as little more than a checkbook to serve
mr. Trump's business and political
interests
we love our vets including at the height
of the presidential primaries wind one
day after mr. Trump raised nearly three
million dollars for veterans is then
campaign manager Corey Lewandowski email
to ask the foundation for some of the
funds the White House did not address
the situation yesterday there's
something that I would refer you the
Trump Organization that's not something
we could comment on but an attorney for
the Trump Foundation said in the past
decade it had distributed approximately
19 million dollars including 8.25
million of the president's personal
money to over 700 charitable
organizations with virtually zero
expenses the Trump Foundation's largest
donation paid to restore a fountain
outside New York's Plaza Hotel then
owned by mr. Trump while it's smallest
donation $7 to the Boy Scouts back in
1989 was the same amount it cost to
enroll his son Donald Jr and when no one
bought a portrait of mr. Trump at
auction the charity wrote a check for
$10,000 the foundation paid $100,000 to
settle a lawsuit over the size of a
flagpole at the president's mar-a-lago
estate
the New York Attorney General said that
the Foundation's 1.8 million dollars of
remaining funds will be distributed to
charities under her supervision and
approved by her office the Trump
Foundation have said it's been trying to
dissolve since 2016 but this matter
impeded that and the underlying facts
found by the Newark attorney general's
office will be turned over
Noora to the Internal Revenue Service
quite a story major thank you